thank you it's my pleasure to be here as
Albert should have been here almost two
months now and it's really great to
speak to you all about some of the work
that I've done in the past about HIV in
the immune system most of this work was
done in San Francisco when I was at UCSF
and really to talk about the interaction
between HIV and the host immune response
so this is not a big history of HIV but
you know the things that are striking
for me is sort of the timeline here in
1981 the first cases of PCP and kaposi
sarcoma started to be recognized in
major metropolitan areas in the United
States boast on both in the east and
west coasts it was recognized a year
later that this syndrome was
characterized by immune deficiency and
the term AIDS was coined acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome and just a
year after that the virus that caused
AIDS was identified and you know just a
little bit about industry I guess since
I've been there three years later the
first drug for HIV was developed and
that's really remarkable to say the
clinical entity was described in 1981
and the first medicine was available in
1986 unfortunately didn't work and HIV
is actually contributed probably the
most or understanding of viral
resistance and the virus becomes
resistant very quickly and patients
continued to die and in nineteen eighty
nineteen ninety-one it became the
leading cause of death in young men in
this country and in 1996 was really when
we developed what has been coined heart
highly active antiretroviral therapy
which is essentially a combination of
medicines that attack different proteins
on the virus are preventing the
development of resistance and that's
when we see you know this curve that
we've seen so many times where we see
the rise and death toll from HIV and
AIDS until 1996 and then this dramatic
decline and which has continued now to
the present
day and why when we see patients in
clinic I think I think all of us would
we see new aids HIV infected patients
always say it's no longer a death
sentence I think everyone has used those
words but but I added these last two
things to the timeline because they
think there's a the work is certainly
not over and in terms of you know
immunology especially there in 2006 I
think the community was quite saddened
that a very large vaccine trial the mark
vaccine trial failed along with a lot of
other smaller vaccine trials that have
still failed which sort of highlights
the fact that we really don't know what
immune response is necessary to prevent
this infection and in terms of the
impact on the ongoing impact there are
still a million people in this country
infected with HIV 33 million worldwide
2.7 new cases yearly and 2 million
deaths annually and so what are the
priorities for HIV care and research now
I think that access to care and access
to medications is a huge one I don't
think I need to tell this audience about
that but a third of folks that that
should be getting medicines don't have
access to those medicines and that's
we're talking about 10 million people
the prevention of new infections in the
treatment of comorbidities is also key
in terms of treatment of patients but
the things that I'm going to talk about
today are sort of the the the key
research topics for HIV immunologists
and what what is sort of been the focus
recently in terms of understanding
damian response to HIV and that is you
know the one of the big goals for for
researchers our continued efforts and
vaccine development and now a renewed
effort in actually trying to cure HIV
and so the first part of my talk will be
to try to understand what are the amina
logic complexities of the host response
that may or may not allow us to get to
these points and then the second issue
is non AIDS related mortality as I said
there's more people live
with HIV now than there were two decades
ago and despite antiretroviral treatment
we're seeing mortality and morbidity
from non AIDS causes and how much of
that is actually due to the consequences
on the immune system so this is usually
two different talks each of which which
takes an hour so I'm going to try to hit
the highlights here to give you a flavor
of the things that the field is
grappling with so I think in terms of
the natural history of HIV so in the
absence of treatment what we see here in
orange after a individual gets infected
we usually see an initial burst of HIV
viral replication we see HIV RNA copies
up to the 10 to the 6th in terms of
copies per milliliter with why
dissemination of the virus to multiple
compartments with a subsequent drop in
viral load and then most individuals
attain some sort of viral set point
which which lasts for eight to ten years
and then the virus comes back again
rising to high rates of replication at
the same time the cd4 t-cell count which
are the cells that HIV actually infects
and depletes they fall dramatically
actually initially after infection some
of that is due to redistribution but
some of that is clearly death of cd4
t-cells they make a slight rebound and
then over the next eight to ten years we
see the slow decline of cd4 t-cells and
when they get to what we call a critical
level of about 200 we start to see an
increased rates of opportunistic
infections malignancies and along with
that rise in viral load and untreated
that will ultimately result in death of
the patient so this is again is what we
see in the vast majority of folks in
terms of the viral load goes up attains
a set point and then goes up again
towards the end of disease what was
recognized relatively early on in the
epidemic is that there were about five
to ten percent of individuals who
actually didn't follow this trajectory
that they did have that initial rise but
then their viral set point was lower and
they did not they survived for a longer
period of time and we didn't see that
viral rebound until several years later
but eventually they did have a rise in
viral load and eventually they did have
drops in cd4 t-cell counts and these
folks were coins long term non
progresses making up about five to ten
percent of the population and they were
really defined not by the virus but by
their ability to maintain cd4 t-cells
and then just in the last five years or
so a new group of individuals have been
identified and now extensively followed
these folks have been coined elite
controllers they make up lesson one
percent of the infected population and
we now know from early infection studies
that did they do have a viral burst
initially but then they're able to
essentially get their virus down to
undetectable levels in the absence of
any therapy and this is a durable
suppression in some individuals over a
decade of being infected with HIV but
we're not able to find the virus in
their blood why does that matter well we
know from very early on that what your
viral set point is predicts your
progression to aids so those with a
viral load of up to 1,000 copies this is
from David hos work back in the mid
actually early 90s that showed if your
viral load was very low your likelihood
of progressing to AIDS in the absence of
therapy was essentially zero and that
has largely been the case for elite
controllers they've maintained their cd4
t-cell counts and except with rare
except for rare exceptions they they do
not get AIDS and they do not have T cell
decline so the majority of Lee
controllers don't progress to AIDS so
should they be a model for functional
HIV cure and that and they've been now
just in the past five years studies
extensively to see if we can mimic their
host response so how do they maintain
their control and there's always a
debate between biologist and
immunologists about what is more
important so one question that with a
surly otters are they really infected
with the virus you know how do we
no we know that they're Sara positive
that's how they're defined as HIV
infected and folks looked at the D in
their DNA their self as well as looking
for ultrasensitive measurements of viral
load in their plasma and they have both
so there certainly have remnants of the
virus somewhere in their system so they
certainly saw HIV but then the question
was well is that virus really you know
able to replicate as other folks viruses
are and some of them actually do have
large deletions and mutations in their
virus that make them less fit but
there's a significant number of folks
that we're replication-competent virus
has been isolated from their blood as
you can imagine this is really difficult
to do you essentially have to do a
leukapheresis in these patients to
actually find the virus stimulate these
cells extremely vigorously to get that
virus to come out but folks have done it
so certainly a certain percentage and
probably we think now the majority of
elite controllers actually have
replication-competent virus somewhere
and I think even more compelling or
transmission pairs so now we've
identified folks where there is a
individual who actually has a non
progressor has replicating virus has
transmitted the virus to the partner and
that partner is an elite controller so
we do think that these folks are
infected with virus so then there's also
focus on the host then what is it about
them that allows them to control the
virus is it the adaptive immune system
is that they need immune system is that
their ability to maintain lower levels
of t-cell activation and that's what I'm
going to talk about now so the studies
that we did when we first started to
identify these individuals there's a
relatively large cohort in San Francisco
called a scope cohort over 7,000
patients are followed longitudinally
basically anyone that wants to be in the
cohort largely can be and every four
months blood saliva and I think for a
while semen has been stored on these
patients so that you can actually you
know follow
their responses their virus over time
and so what we did was we took cells
from these individuals and stimulated
them with HIV peptides to see what type
of immune response to HIV these
individuals manifested so the groups of
individuals that we study are elite
controller so essentially they have
documented low viral loads off of
therapy and then we have three
comparator groups there's virey me
control errs which are almost a version
of elite controllers they have slightly
higher viral loads detectable all the
time but they're also off therapy these
are almost like your traditional
long-term non progressor so they have
virus around they don't control as well
as the elite then we have non controller
so this is like the vast majority of
other untreated population they have
high levels of viral load and then the
last group which i think is a very
important comparison group or folks that
are on therapy with suppressed virus so
the virus is a whole lot of stuff when
it's around to the immune system so we
really wanted this population to control
for the level of virus to allow us to
really look at the immune system in the
absence of RL replication to make those
comparisons so just in terms of the
demographics they were all essentially
in all groups were in their mid-40s
infected for a relatively long period of
time most of them over a decade if you
look at their cd4 t-cell counts and we
didn't choose these groups based on T
cells but based on their virus elite
controllers have a nice this is actually
a normal cd4 t-cell count in the 700
that these are median values controllers
are slightly lower in the mid 400s as
you would predict patients with high
level viral replication their cd4 count
is in the 200 we purposely didn't pick
individuals that have very low cd4
t-cell counts because they're really
towards the end stage disease and that
can impact your your immune system in
various ways as well and then folks that
are suppressed with therapy have about a
50 for cat in the mid 400s as well so
the first thing we looked at was t cell
activation in HIV and why do we care
about T cell
activation so essentially this is a
measurement of a couple of markers on
the surface of cd8 t-cell cd38 and
hla-dr cdat cells that have these
markers are activated most of them are
not infected well the CD aids are not
infected but even cd4s with these
markers are not infected with HIV this
is bystander activation in the setting
of high levels of virus and back in the
90s Janice Georgie from UCLA actually
showed that t-cell activation was a
better predictor of mortality from HIV
than viral load and we know now the T
cell activation actually predicts your
ability to respond to antiretroviral
therapy with cd4 games so when we looked
at elite controllers we can see compared
to the very meek controllers so these
are like your long-term non progresses
they have a significantly lower level of
t-cell activation compared to those
controllers not surprisingly patients
with high level viral replication have
really high levels of t-cell activation
this is forty percent of your t-cell cd8
t-cells actually look like they're you
know freaking out basically I mean
there's nothing that they're not
hiv-specific this is just bystander
activation they're acting like they're
ready to fight something and that's not
surprising and that's been reported
before now if you look at individuals
that are suppressed on therapy you can
see when you go from an untreated high
level vile replication to treatment your
t-cell activation drops dramatically and
people have reported that before now if
you compare these two groups now both of
these groups don't have much virus
around your elite controllers actually
have slightly higher t-cell activation
than folks on therapy and to me this is
actually a not another piece of evidence
that these folks are infected with virus
there is viral replication going on
somewhere it might not be in the blood
but this is not a normal level of t-cell
activation and here's your HIV negative
group so whether you're on therapy and
suppressed of ours or whether you're not
on therapy and suppress the virus your
levels of t-cell activation are not
normal so something is going on
somewhere that's making your cd8 cells
not completely happy so after T cell
activation we wanted to look at the HIV
the t-cell response to HIV and we looked
at the literature there's a lot of
literature about long term non
progresses they have very robust cd4 and
cd8 t-cell responses to HIV we know that
when you remember that first slide where
the viral load is up and then it dropped
suddenly about four to six weeks after
infection well that core there's a very
strong correlation with a drop of viral
load and the rise of hiv-specific teeth
health we know in the macaque model if
you actually get rid of cd8 t-cells your
viral load goes through the roof and
then we and others have shown that dual
functional t-cells those would secrete
both interferon gamma and il-2 are
actually associated with good viral
control so we started with this and said
well let's look at the t cells and elite
controllers and see if they control in
the same way as the long term non
progresses have and i would say
essentially the answer is looks like
it's yes so if you look at your elite
controllers and your by remote
controllers they both have you know this
is a gag protein we've done this with
envelope with neffs of multiple HIV
proteins but gag is the most robust
peripheral response so you can see that
you know there is a nice t-cell cd8
t-cells and these are I'm sorry these
are CD fours and you can see it's much
higher than what we find individuals
that have high levels of virus so the
non controllers and interestingly once
you go on therapy you actually largely
lose your peripheral HIV response
because you know there's not a whole lot
you're reacting to so when you take the
cells out of the body there's not a lot
of hiv-specific responses out there so
essentially we've shown that elite
controllers and varied controllers do
have this robust cd4 anti-hiv response
and the same is true when we look at cd8
again these are the dual functional cd8
that secrete both interferon gamma and
il-2
Elite controllers environment
controllers clearly have higher t-cell
responses compared to all of the other
groups and this is just our HIV negative
control to which understandably there's
no response to HIV there so looks like
okay well maybe this is this is why
there are lead controllers they have
these great t-cell responses this is
something we've known all along and this
might be what we should aim for in a
vaccine or when we think about curative
approaches but you know and i think as
many folks in the audience know you know
how you show the data makes a big
difference so if you look at the actual
individuals that were used in this
analysis and you look at the spread the
higher levels of t-cell response in
these two groups are really not driven
you know by the whole group there are
some folks that have no hiv-specific
t-cell response and yet they still
control the virus to undetectable levels
and this is you know a sizable
proportion of both the elite controllers
and the very make controlled and they
look just like the non controllers and
heart suppress individuals and so the
next question we asked is you know well
why is that are these folks different
than these folks in some way and do they
control the virus in different ways so
we focus then on HLA so HLA molecules
are on the surface of antigen presenting
cells they're responsible for binding
foreign things sometimes self as well
bacteria viruses and essentially they
present the peptides of that foreign
foreign protein to cd8 t-cells and the t
cell receptor on the cd8 t-cells
recognizes the combination of the HLA
molecule and this little piece of
bacteria or virus that's there and then
goes on to kill that cell that's
infected and there's a huge genetic
diversity in terms of HLA everyone here
has their signature HLA type with lots
of different variants and actually very
early when people were looking at HLA in
HIV we knew that there were some HLA
types that were associated with a bed
prognosis to HIV a longer or delayed
progression to aids and those in the
literature if you look hla-b 57 and be
27 are the ones that are most often
cited there are others be 13 b 58 b 81
all of which have been associated with
long-term non progression so we looked
at our cohort and we said you know
within the elite and the very meek
controller group what is what is the
prevalence of these protective HLA
alleles and you can see that there is a
high higher percentage of protective
alleles in the allele in the elites and
the very me controller compared to the
non controllers and then we asked well
is the t-cell responses and the
heterogeneity that we saw is it
explained by a chili and it seems to be
when you look at the data this way so we
looked at the controllers that have a
protective allele compared to those that
don't have a protective allele and we
looked at that you know optimal dual
functional cd8 t-cell response that that
we're aiming for and you can see that
those that do have a protectable ill
have a significantly higher t-cell
response compared to those that don't
have that t-cell response and when you
look at the nod controllers there are
some folks that have those good alleles
and the non controllers as well but
universally all of the non controllers
have poor cd8 t-cell responses and
there's no difference between those that
don't have the controller's versus the
non controllers that don't have a
protective alleles so what that
basically says is if you have an HLA
protective HLA allele it's not necessary
for good control of the virus nor is it
sufficient for control of the virus you
really have to have you know the right
hla type with a good CD for response to
really fall in this controller group but
what was really intriguing is that there
are a bunch of people that don't have
protective HLAs don't have good cd4
t-cell responses but still control their
virus to undetectable levels
and so that's where my story ended and
that's when I left for genentech but
it's interesting that you know this
question is still a very active question
in the field of HIV to understand this
heterogeneity under in the elite
controllers and which what are the
aspects of the immune response in these
folks that actually allow them to
control virus and are there aspects in
these folks that we can actually mimic
either in a vaccine strategy or an
eradication strategy so in terms of a
summary of the elite controllers we they
maintain tight viral control of viral
replication despite being effect
infected with a replication-competent
virus but there are very heterogeneous
group you know now you're talking about
less than one percent of your HIV
infected group and there's heterogeneity
within that as well we think that HLA
allele they're certainly enriched but
there they don't explain the whole
picture because they're not neither
necessary nor sufficient for viral
control so I think the way that I try to
think about this and I don't want to
ignore the fact that there's viral
diversity either but I think in the
elite that there probably are a group of
them that are infected with defective
virus replication incompetent virus and
so there's zero positive but they
actually don't have an ongoing viral
replication there's probably another
group that is infected with virus and
they have a strong t-cell response
either due to prior exposure or just
because they have a protective HLA and
that allows them to kill the virus prior
to CD for infection or more likely that
they have a low level infection and the
CD 40s and cd8 t-cells keep that in
check and then I think what we're really
interested in learning is that there's
probably a group that have other arms of
the immune response that actually allow
them to control their buyers that either
initially during that initial burst can
control the virus or it lowers the peak
viral load enough to let the adaptive
immune response sort of take over so are
the elite controllers a model for cure I
would say maybe but they're small unique
group and they do represent the ideal
response to
try the infection and we're trying to
mimic their host responses but I think
we're relatively early in terms of
understanding the elite controllers and
understanding the diversity and it's
going to be really important as we tease
out the optimal immune response to make
sure that we don't group the elite
controllers into one entity and trying
to understand which of their immune
responses we can actually actually mimic
one thing I will say is that we can't
really mimic the protective HLA strong
cd8 t-cell response because we either
have be 57 or we don't and though we
can't really mimic in every individual a
strong b-57 mediated in response because
everyone can't do it so which is why I
think this if we can mimic this side
that will be something that is
potentially achievable for a larger
percent of the population but we're
still trying to understand what that
site is so that was part one in terms of
the complexities of the HIV response now
I'm going to turn to the consequences of
HIV on the ninety to ninety-five percent
of individuals that are infected with
HIV and aren't lucky enough to control
their visors in the absence of therapy
but actually need therapy and as I
talked about before the P the number of
individuals living with HIV is continues
to rise given that we have 2.7 million
new infections a year the antiretroviral
therapies if you have access to them
actually work and so so the number of
people living with HIV continues to rise
this is another version of the slide I
showed before with a dramatic fall and
mortality but this is divided into
mortality that is related to aids aids
aids related causes versus non
aids-related causes and it's hard to see
because the black is is so low compared
to the age-related cases but you'll have
to trust me when I tell you that the
rates of morbidity and mortality from
non AIDS related cases has never dropped
even with
the institution of highly active
antiretroviral therapy and now looks
like it's probably rising as this
population continues to age what is that
morbidity it's cardiovascular disease
liver disease kidney disease metabolic
disorders we're seeing a hyperlipidemia
increased rates of diabetes we're seeing
osteoporosis and we're seeing particular
malignant malignancies that are
increased at incident and not only are
these increased in incidents we're also
seeing a lot of these conditions at a
much younger age than you would expect
in an HIV uninfected counterparts
cardiovascular disease for example
individuals are having a thrombotic
strokes and heart attacks at least a
decade earlier than you would expect one
to control for risk factors and some of
these conditions have been associated in
the non HIV population with alterations
in in the immune response so so what I
wanted to look at is you know once you
put individuals on therapy what parts of
their immune response gets better and
what parts doped and so I'm going to
talk about some of the measurements that
we looked at including cd4 cd8 ratio
naive t cells cd28 expansion and then
talk a little bit about the similarities
between HIV disease and aging in terms
of the immune system so the groups that
we studied here once again we this is
our main group now which is the
antiretroviral they treated individuals
who are suppressed on therapy and I've
been suppressed on therapy for some time
in to compare that with individuals that
are not on therapy and have high viral
loads and then I think what is
increasingly being recognized as now
that we're able to get virus
undetectable we have to really get very
well controlled HIV negative groups to
see what is that continued residual
difference in in these controlled groups
so this is a again individuals largely
in
or 40s non controllers and hearts
oppressed been infected for a median of
15 and 10 years you can see the cd4
count is higher in those that are
intuitive i relay treated and of course
they're viral load is undetectable by
definition so the first thing we looked
at was just numbers of cd4 and cd8
normally we should have twice as many
cd4s those are our helper T cells
compared to cd8 cells and we know in the
non HIV population when that ratio gets
flipped when you have more cdh than cd4s
that's actually a predictor of mortality
and we also know we know that T cell
activation is bad for HIV we also know
that this inverted ratio is directly
correlated to your levels of t cell
activation so what we looked at was HIV
negative individuals and these
individuals were somewhat matched to our
to our HIV infected group in that they
in terms of demographics these were
individuals that were presenting for
post-exposure prophylaxis after high
risk behavior in San Francisco so you
can see the HIV negative population this
is the normal cd4 cd8 ratio twice as
many cd4s compared to cd8 you can see in
individuals that are have replication of
their virus and are not on therapy
dramatic drop I mean this is a one to
four ratio in terms of cd4 to see the
AIDS and this has been reported as early
as the late to 80s that this is what
happens when you don't treat HIV what we
would have liked to see when we put
folks on therapies that you go you know
right back up there we don't see that
but we certainly see a statistical
increase in your cd4 cd8 ratio but it's
still point five it's still inverted so
then we looked at the city fours and cd8
separately to see which aspect of that
ratio is driving this response so we
know that when you're not on therapy
your depletion of cd4s is really a
dramatic as is the increase in seating
gates and this happens pretty early
after infection so which explains that
you know ratio point 25 though you gain
some of your CD eights back when a cd4
is back when you go on therapy you don't
really lose your cd8 which is why you
have this persistent lower ratio and we
don't know yet whether that is good or
bad but it's just an observation at this
point so we wanted to look at those cd4
and cd8 that remain and to say well is
there something different about them
that we should be concerned so one thing
that we wanted to look at is teeth we
did t cell subset so essentially when
you have a t-cell cd4 cd8 it's when it
comes out of the thymus it's a naive
cell it's just hanging out waiting for a
pathogen a tumor or something to respond
to when it sees that antigen it begins
to differentiate and a bunch of cells
become effector cells and those are
basically your killer t-cells are out
there to kill the cells that are
infected with virus they're out there to
kill the tumor cells and once they've
done that then most of them died and
then a few of them revert to a memory
population waiting to see that virus
again and then there's another group of
naive felt it will actually immediately
go into that memory population knowing
that maybe this will happen again and
then eventually after the antigen is
cleared then you know there's different
phenotypes of these memory population
that essentially manifest with different
functions so you're naive cells they're
able to proliferate really well they
secrete il-2 your effector cells secrete
perforin granzyme interferon these are
cytokines that essentially are have the
ability to kill their target cell and
then you have this memory population
that's sort of a combination of the two
they proliferate a little bit the
secretes a mile to they can secrete
interferon gamma but you know these
subsets of cells are essentially you
know they're they're there to to be able
these cells are there to be able to
proliferate in the setting of a second
infection
and they're also there to be able to you
know kill pretty quickly if they need to
what we're waiting for that affect your
response so we used four different
markers to identify our t-cell subsets
and I've just laid them out here from
what I consider naive to memory or
affect your populations and we used for
because we want it to be really
confident that these are naive t cells
so we used a bunch of markers and we
want it to be really confident that
these are effector T cells so we used
you know at the time what was really
sophisticated multi-parameter flow
cytometry to be able to identify these
cells so these are HIV uninfected
individuals and you're looking at their
cd8 t-cells and you can see the vast
majority of your t-cells are naive
they're just hanging out there they're
not facing any sort of problem right now
they're just waiting to see that next
infection in the setting of HIV these
are folks not on therapy you see a
dramatic drop in your naive t cell
population and you see a big increase in
these effector cells well there have a
chronic infection they have a virus all
all these cells are there's more and
more effector cells and these are
constant these naive cells are
constantly proliferating and
differentiating into these other subsets
when you go on antiretroviral therapy
you're essentially taking away the
infection so what I think we would have
liked to see is that then you get your
naive t cells back and your effector T
cells go away because you really don't
need them right now and this is what we
thought I don't know why my error bars
are not on there but we do have error
bars but essentially there's absolutely
no change even though you've taken away
your antigen and these effector cells
should largely die off they don't they
don't seem to and you're not getting
your naive t cells back and that was
striking and of you know concern because
now when we know what naive t cells do
they respond to cancer they respond to
new invading pathogens and we know you
know that as you age you sort of you
lose these naive t cells and that's
associated with sort of badness over
time because you're not
able to appropriately respond to the
infections that you should be we looked
at this another way in terms of cd28
cd28 negative T fills are essentially
what we call they're not only senescent
cells but they're also reflective of a
senescent person so as you age you get
more and more cd28 negative T cells and
you and you can see again an HIV you
lose your cd28 positive you gain ear
2228 negative and essentially again
unchanged in the setting of
antiretroviral treatment and
interestingly Rita F roses also at UCLA
looked at the telomere length of
individuals with HIV and essentially
they were which again is a marker of
senescent and they were equivalent in
length to HIV uninfected individuals in
their 90's essentially so just in
summary of the consequences of HIV on
the immune system and the persistent
impact of HIV on the immune system
despite therapy so we see there's
continued decrease an inversion of the
cd4 cd8 ratio there's continued decrease
of naive t cells there's persistent cd28
negative expansion what I haven't shown
you the data but there's also increased
secretion of these affect your like
cytokines and there's increased CMV
specific responses also has been
associated with senescence and now I'm
going to tell you what happens in the
literature for when you look at
individuals in terms of extreme age
inverted cd4 cd8 ratio decline in cd4
t-cells lower naive memory t-cell ratio
accumulation of cd20 and negative cells
increase production of interferon gamma
decreased production of il-2 increase
the envy seropositivity and increase
levels or pro-inflammatory cytokines so
essentially all of the phenomenon that
we see in HIV both untreated and treated
is what we see in the aging population
and I've sort of highlighted the ones
that there's a clinical correlation with
so the inverted ratio the accumulation
of C
negative cells and the sea of these
specific response have all been
associated with increased mortality in
the non HIV population so what what does
that mean given that our HIV population
is increasing and our HIV infected
population is aging and these are the
questions that many people are looking
at which is does HIV actually cause
premature aging of the immune system and
do the phenotypes that we have
identified and maybe some other a burn
sees that we haven't looked at yet are
they actually correlated to clinical
outcomes in this patient population did
they improve with time on therapy so you
know our folks were you know treated for
anywhere from three to five years well
what if they're been treated for a
decade did they get better does earlier
treatment so maybe if we didn't wait
till their t cells were 50 before we
treated them but we treat them when
their t cells were 400 maybe we wouldn't
see that and then what's the
contribution of the therapy itself to
these aberrant responses and some of the
things that we're doing right now is
trying to address some of these issues
we're now with the vax cohort which is
based out of the VA here dr. Amy
justices is the PI of that cohort we're
looking at carefully controlled studies
of HIV infected and uninfected
individuals because what I showed you
was not controlled for age which is
obviously a very important variable to
look at we're also looking at the
association of these phenotypes with
clinical outcomes so do individuals that
have cardiovascular outcomes have
particular immunologic phenotypes that
could predict that or individuals with
particular malignancies and we're also
looking at longitudinal evaluation of
patients on heart because we do have now
the ability everyone staying on
antiretroviral therapy for years we can
look at individuals three years later
and every three years if we wanted to to
see when we see the change in the immune
system so this is essentially a flavor
of two of the big areas of HIV research
is going on and translational research
of
the and the immune system and some of
the stuff i'll be continuing here at
Yale but I do want to acknowledge the
folks that help me generate this data
back in San Francisco Mike McCune and
Steve Deeks or my mentors during
fellowship as well as Doug Nixon and
Jeff Martin who also were involved with
the scope cohort a Walter moreto in the
lab that helped me do a lot of those
studies and other folks all involved
with the positive health program at at
San Francisco General Hospital thank you